rebalanced we saw that Shakura are very
resourceful turning around difficult
positions quite a lot but in other
aspects Duda was slightly ahead so um
yeah it's going to be very very close
match and there we go the final has
started yeah here we go a queen's Pawn
opening what we'll do to choose to play
here okay it's a variation called the
nimso Indian with Black's Bishop coming
out very early pinning that white knight
and uh a solid variation this is
regarded as very solid for whites not
taking too many risks usually here white
gets a set of double Pawns in this
opening but not now although West Queen
has spent quite a bit of time
so far chakra has played this plenty of
times I think so he has and also very a
favorite of Gary Kasparov Vichy Anand
and here I can see that in 2018 Mama
giraffe did in fact draw this game with
the white pieces against Fabby Fabiana
Carolina I should say yeah my major I
think I remember games as far back as
2014 maybe even earlier where he was
playing this variation and he's got a
very solid reputation for black uh
Black's last move very logical
um I had this myself recently actually
from the white side but often Black's
Bishop as well goes to attack that White
Queen that would have been another
option White's Queen is the vulnerable
piece she often has to lose a lot of
time in this variation on the plus side
white has the two Bishops white has an
extra Pawn in the center of the board
right now and the White Knight Springs
forward yeah this one I'm just checking
is not the most popular move in fact
played once by Jordan van Forrest
against uh vidit and January 2020. 22 to
what was that
yeah yeah okay so that was uh very uh
very theoretical battle between Jordan
vanfriest very well known opening
theoretician and vidit opening expert La
Majora the fact he's played this so
quickly means he's studied that game
before
and uh yeah it's it's interesting like
you said normally with the white knight
doesn't spring forward because it's kind
of breaking the rules that night's
already been developed once to move it
twice before you've completed developing
your other pieces before you've castled
as white it feels a bit risky it just
definitely does especially when you add
in the fact that the queen has also been
on a journey as well I mean it's much
more standard to actually relocate The
Rook in the corner just move that one to
an open line but instead we have this
wild position and I can tell you that uh
when vidit faced this particular move
with the black pieces he actually
stepped forward with the queen two
squares and he got ready to break out
into the center and challenge the Deep
Pawn by pushing C5 yeah this is white
stronghold in the center you want to
undermine it you want to attack it this
would be very logical uh what how did
the game continue There you like it
um okay so oh we've seen it okay so uh
well our white play to the move E3
liberating the light squared bishop and
then C5 came okay and uh then Bishop
retreated to the F4 Square asking
questions of the black queen yeah
indirectly threatening her and uh yeah
very tense position I guess uh often we
see this type of scenario and even if
the Black Wing was to drop back
um it's all about Pawn structures so if
black can take the white Pawn on his
terms for example now let's say white
moves The Rook uh just in this example
the poor structure is very symmetrical
very balanced and chances tend to be
roughly level but if white can do the
damage to the Blackboard structure for
example it going back to this position
if white can take this black one black
has other options but if black captures
then white is better because these two
are separated so it's small margins
we're talking about tiny little details
like Pawn structure but that's uh that's
the theme now for the middle game
Shakura are looking for ways to increase
the white Advantage long term he's got
the bishop pair that this is the current
position and how to utilize it this
one's still fast asleep at home
okay is
he's definitely going to get developed
and uh whilst mamidarov is considering
what to do we are expecting the pawn to
push forward well we are running a
competition today so we're asking you at
home to send us your best chess joke and
one lucky winner will win
our good friend Simon Ginger GM mug and
uh you can send us your jokes use on
Twitter using the hashtag chess Champs
do you know any chest jokes
we had one yesterday about uh Checkmate
check yeah dating in Prague yeah looking
for a Checkmate and I I remember the
punch line of one joke which was like
yeah it was a rookie mistake aha
famous one it's uh chestnuts boasting on
an open yeah yeah chestnuts boasting on
an open fire oh yeah yeah so it's like
what did yeah but there must be better
ones out there yeah that's a Christmas
cracker joke yeah
I bet our viewers have the coolest chest
stroke so please send them for a chance
to win this very nice coffee mug or tea
cup whatever you want to use it for
Imagine starting your day with Simon
Williams
start to the day yeah we miss him and
this is our way of acknowledging that
yeah
yeah meanwhile dude uh how surprised my
major off seemingly I was praising Mama
door for having done his research his
opening research so well being aware of
that game but due to kind of continues
in the way we expected following that
game and mamador stops right and we
barely we barely got to see the aim
chest stats before it started so maybe
we should bring them up again just uh
do you think these are very correct
according to their Styles and I'm
especially thinking of Muhammad Yara
with the accuracy which is very high
I mean mama joro stats are surprising in
the accuracy but also he's a
self-proclaimed you know middle game
lover the end game stats are very high
for my major of 75 so I'm slightly
surprised they are that high in terms of
accuracy and end game but he's a very
good player as we know and Duda nearly
matches him in those two departments
anyway
um yeah my major of the head-on
Advantage capitalization ahead and
resourcefulness to ahead on everything
except for the size 7s and wins exactly
so decisiveness that means due to wins
and loses more which is really
surprising manager is known as a player
who's kind of a lot All or Nothing type
of Chess so some surprises more undue uh
more than sorry mamajaro's side than do
decide do the side looks at least to me
relatively accurate
yeah we'll see how those uh
how those stats play off in this match
how about the way they spend time who is
more sensible when it comes to spending
time because Mom and you're now spent
four minutes on this move and he plays
them if we expected uh the most natural
move yeah that's a very good question
Kai actually both of these two players
they they can play very quickly when
they were in the flow when they're on
form when they're confident but we have
seen Duda occasionally get into time
travel when he plays the very best
players like Magnus uh we see a shark
occasionally get into time trouble but
that's normally when he's struggling on
the board as well if Shaq's doing well
in the position he very rarely pauses
for too long
so um yeah a four minute think there
still in the opening
slightly worrying this is one thing I
noticed when I've played Shaq myself as
well of course he's very well prepared
but
it's maybe not to the same level as some
of the very top players in the world the
caruanas the
um the magnuses they know all the little
details Shaq sometimes stops and then
he's like yeah I'll freestyle it from
here or it looks like my type of
position but uh he has to work it out
over the board himself and uh still
continuing along those lines that we
mentioned earlier and on that point I
mean I do remember Anish Gary's
interview where he talked about the game
where shaqueria just played the best
game of his life and he said the
scenario was actually very similar to
this type of game you know he he played
the opening very slowly and Anish
thought right
he's got nothing on the table he's got
no hidden surprises and then before you
knew it
he was just wiped off the board I mean
he had no chance whatsoever so uh that
was a surprise and a mama jarf is
capable of that yes okay maybe he might
be freestyling in the opening but he's
very capable of figuring out what are
the best moves and putting the pressure
on Duda and that's what he needs to do
and just to kind of come just to
reinforce in the one game that I have on
the database in this particular position
the white Bishop of sitting on G5 just
retreated one square to face off against
the queen
you think Mama Jara will play that or do
you think he'll play something a bit
more
to know it feels like it's not my
Majora's style to retreat so I have a
feeling he won't drop back white starts
going Bishop he'll maybe bring White's
Rook to the center
trying to find what else to do it's
actually quite hard to suggest moves why
tonight doesn't really want to move when
it's Pawn in the center is stuck
defending that white knight White's
Queen doesn't look like it has anywhere
to go so
I'm going to narrow it down I'll see
it's that white Rook or it's the white
dots going Bishop yeah how about you I
think the more I look at the position
the more retreating the dark squared
Bishop makes sense because it reinforces
the protection of the Knight and then
allows you to lies white that is to
capture the on the pawn on C5 yeah so
this is the pawn you want to capture
first you need to defend your knight
um you know of course if you capture the
spawn now the Knight just drops off to
the black queen so that's the reasoning
for this move the bishop dropping back
also creates a threat so after Pawn
takes Pawn I guess we can jump out with
our Knight not sure exactly where for
example here and it's a double attack
hitting the queen hitting the Black Rock
as well we'll win one of those two
pieces
um so that would create a direct threat
in the current position
now I was also wondering it feels like
it might be Shaq's style to just move oh
sorry you're going to say Ivanka Bishop
takes Knight I was running through the
ccts I'm trying to make it a point that
uh when I look at these positions like
checks captures threats okay because I
forget them makes sense and this is an
alternative as well and you leave black
with double pawns the problem the one
downside is that the Knight is attacked
now you have to retreat it
and where'd you go you could go back
this way buying up this Pawn maybe
planting a check at some point but you
don't have any Escape squares here so if
black can deal with this maybe okay he
does play this move wow Ivanka you're
right checks captures and threats he
captures the Knight and uh the problem
here that I was seeing is that for
example black can continue attacking
this Knight and you're running out of
squares maybe you can give a check uh
we're gonna see what Shakura has in mind
in the current position but
big question where is he going to put
this Knight he's moved his Queen three
times as white he's moved his dark
squared Bishop twice it's gone now and
now this Knight is going to have to move
a third time he's Breaking All the Rules
managero don't move the same piece more
than once in the opening that's what
they say he's forgetting that one and uh
you have to be good in order to break
the rules
he's good enough but also not that many
attacking pieces if you Retreat this
Knight for example back here or back
here you're still playing without your
Bishop without your Rooks
it doesn't feel too great
I've got to say Judah looks very calm
yeah he looks like such a boss sitting
like that
looks like an evil
James Bond villain yeah
just missing the cat on the lap right
yeah I mean oh are the players allowed
to have a cat or a pet oh definitely
didn't we I mean Wesley so have his cat
yeah ponchook has been
I was saying yeah in the room but on the
lap oh and yeah the Knight does retreat
to the square one from where it came
from we're not allowed any external
assistance right during chess so what
happens if the cat suddenly meows out a
good word no good move okay I don't know
well then I think distracting for the
players too if the cat meows out
with the horse and then I think cheating
is not the first thing we think about
then we call some circus uh and yeah
we'll be rich yeah meanwhile the night
drops back to the square it came from
and I've got to say
it doesn't look too impressive to me
what Shaq is doing again freestyling
that's guaranteed at this point he spent
a lot of time on the clock chakra five
almost five minutes down uh on time and
his Knight's back where it came from yes
he's doubled the black pawns but in this
opening variation you normally double
the black points anyway so you just kind
of wasted two moves with a white knight
and you haven't really achieved much you
might still needs a move with the bishop
white still needs to get his King to
safety
so Duda here can try to set a Pawns in
the center he can just develop Black's
Knight
um would you capture the White Knight
this is a big question I guess that's
dudes contemplating if I say no I would
not touch that night at all with a he's
not even
not even if you tempted me not even if
you offered me money David I would say
absolutely not because I mean just to
compare the two the Black Knight sorry
the black Bishop is just beautiful it's
sitting on a long diagonal it's
potentially pointing to where the king
is going to go I mean much better to get
developed move the night put the Rooks
towards the center I think the black
king is safe even though it is exposed
yeah
better you could always hide in the
corner if it needs to yeah exactly I
mean there's no dark Square Bishop to
terrorize black so yeah keep keep the
tension I don't even think I would trade
pawns as well I would keep that on the
board for as long as possible so let
white trade on his uh on your terms
essentially so bring the Black Knight
out that looks like the most sensible
move to me as well I'm just wondering
because Duda is thinking now for over
two minutes is he slightly tempted he
loves a kind of imbalanced positions
whether it's Bishops versus Knights
queen versus two Rooks some kind of
imbalance to material uh situations he
loves that type of thing so Bishop takes
Knight it I agree it doesn't look great
but for example after Pawn takes Pawn
okay there's a file open towards the
black king but also where is White's
King going it's not really going this
way or at least
I don't think so but I don't think Shaq
would even capture the pawn in the
center he would give it away yeah he'd
give it away and maybe you do Castle
queenside I was going to say there's no
safe haven for the king but uh here
maybe white could get away with castling
because the king is actually running
away to safety and instead Duda doesn't
go for this capture maybe he's scared of
opening up a line towards the black king
very sensible instead he just trades a
set of Pawns and uh wow a queen exchange
as well has happened and Black's night
has come out it looks like we're headed
towards very dull equality in this game
so far Knights are off the board as well
look at the pawn structure apart from
this small blemish for black it's
completely level
and all white needs to do to equalize
this game is bring the bishop out okay
he's going to push the pawn first just
to cut this Bishop's diagonal he's going
to bring his Bishop out move his King
and uh yeah the white Rooks will connect
I think we'll see a quick draw
unfortunately wow I I I said that to
both of you actually I suspect that the
position you know I said to you that the
way that these two play you know there
will be some action right at the
beginning there will be some potential
heat and then it will be decided very
very quickly I mean I have noticed these
games they play with each other I mean
they're just very aggressive early on
and usually when that's the case the
complications fizzle out or they Sizzle
and you have a result yeah very quickly
well I kind of like it yeah it's uh it's
fast and furious chess yeah okay this
one turned out to be most likely a draw
but uh we will see games where it's fast
furious and it's decided in one side's
favor yeah exactly um yeah neither of
these players then not really known for
their long grinds and uh for trying to
you know outlast tire out the opponent
no uh rook and Bishop fun game uh the
Ricks and Bishops are on the board still
oh but yeah this one is so balanced I'm
expecting as well because there are two
open lines on the board the C file and
the D file and those two open lines the
Rooks will come to them they'll swap off
they'll neutralize each other
and uh yeah draw look at Duda he's he
knows as well not much life left in this
one but
it's a good result for doodle we've got
to say Shaq is so much more dangerous
with white than he is with black
um Shaq with black just can't get his
type of attacking position quite often
or at least if you don't give it to him
he struggles sometimes
but uh yeah with white he's blown many
players off the board not do that in
this one though no
absolutely not
and okay
so say let's pretend that Shaq is in a
must-win situation
he wouldn't have chosen this uh
but somehow he did and this is the
position that's in front of him if he
wanted to grind it out
into a whim how would the grind Master
do it
even I would struggle to drag this game
much longer
um I guess one idea for white long term
imagine all the Rooks disappear from the
board then white king could start
walking White's King can walk towards
that black H Pawn Black's H porn over
there on the side is isolated
the problem is you can't get too far if
the black king blocks you off but I
guess you could walk towards that I
would put all of White's pawns on dark
squares long term because you have a
light Square Bishop
I mean Black's Pawn weakness the double
death pawns the problem is you don't
have Knights to go and attack them
Knights are the best piece of the
attacking kind of porn weaknesses not
Bishops so it's yes it's hard hard work
right optimism we need to do that you
need to do that to basically give you a
helping hand and I agree with you it's
very very difficult to see I mean for me
I I wouldn't have actually dreamed above
exchanging Rooks I thought well perhaps
the white worker could try to take
control of the sea lion and try to
control that one
um
is that a possibility so for instance
the white work can step forward attack
the bishop yeah uh so blacksmooth first
of all I'm guessing that Duda for
example let's say he just plays a quiet
move uh the problem is if you try and
occupy one open file black will stop you
there black can challenge
um I'm not sure exactly what you do here
the problem is if you ever move the
white king you have to be slightly
careful that the black Rook doesn't come
down uh to the second rank okay he plays
a more uh aggressive move and uh putting
his Bishop on the edge of the board
maybe dude is the one playing for the
win if he's stopping the white Rook
using this Square uh to challenge black
supremity uh Supremacy sorry on the D
file oh but oh David David I think we're
potentially seeing a repetition Brewing
okay look they're gonna play copycats
the Bishops are gonna flee from each
other and keep on doing this dance Flex
Bishop moves whites Bishop will go back
and say please trade and uh yeah you'll
write your Banker I don't think actually
black wants to trade off Bishops because
suddenly that would help white uh
activate his Rook from the corner and
that's why the players there doing that
dance I think we'll see a draw any
moment Shaq is repeating the position
and uh let's go back to the players
results of very quick results in game
one it looks like
20 minutes the first game is about to
last okay Mama jar of
double checking if there is anything
but there isn't it's a draw the first
game after 20 minutes they finish with a
draw mama jarov with the white pieces so
now he only has one more game in this
first